حول هذا الموضوع معنا الان من الخرطوم
مراسل الجزيره الطاهر المرضي ومن القدس
مراسل الجزيره الياس كرم ارحب بكم وابدا
معك الطاهر المرضي ان كانت قد رشحت اي
معلومات على المستوى الرسمي السوداني حول
هذه الزياره وهذا اللقاء
نعمل معلومات التي تم تاكيدها هي وصول هذا
الوفد الرفيع ربما بقياده وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الى الخرطوم ودخل في مباحثات
مع المجلس السياده بشكل جدي وواضحا هذه
العلاقات الان تتجدد بعد ان توقفت الى
فتره من الزمن ولكن البين فيها هو ان هذه
العلاقه او ان السودان قد حسم امره في
المضيق قدما في مساله التطبيع مع اسرائيل
وربما توقيع اتفاقيات اتفاقيات مهدت لها
توقيع السودان مع الولايات المتحده حول
هذه الاتفاقيات اتفاقيات ابراهام واليوم
هذه الزياره ربما يكون لها ما بعدها وربما
هنالك توقيع ايضا قريب ليكمل التطبيع مع
اسرائيل او بين الخرطوم وتل ابيب هذه
الخطوه تعتبر خطوه عمليه خاصه وعلى الرغم
من ان كان هنالك تقدم ممانعه من السودان
اتجاه هذه الخطوه ولكن اللقاء رئيس مجلس
السياده برئيس الوزراء
بنيامين يتنياهو في عشرين عشرين كان قد
رفع هذا
السريه في التعامل مع تل ابيب واصبحت الان
الامور اشبه بان تكون اكثر وضوحا ولكن على
الرغم من ان هنا في السودان هناك تكتم
كبير على هذه المفاوضات والملفات التي
تتناولها ولكن المصادر تتحدث عن اربعه او
ثلاثه ملفات رئيسيه جانب سياسي والجانب
الامني وكذلك الجانب التطبيع الكامل بين
الدولتين في هذا الاطار وربما توقيع ايضا
ينتهي الى هذه المساله رغم التعسر الذي
كان قد صاحب هذه العلاقات في فتره
حكومه رئيس الوزراء عبد الله حمدوك قال ان
هذا التطبيق هو شان للبرلمان المنتقب
ويرجع في هذا الاطار
ان هذا الجانب رغمي انه انه قد تعثر ولكن
اليوم تجدد بشكل اقوى وان الوصفات التي
يقوم بها الرئيس الرئيس الامريكي في هذا
الاطار يبدو انها تاتي او التسير على قدر
وثائق ربما نشهد خلال هذه خلال هذا اليوم
تطور اكبر مما كنا نتوقعه اذا تطور اكبر
متوقع وهنا انتقل اليك كرام اهميه هذه
الزياره وابرز المكاسب التي تحققها حكومه
نتنياهو
بالفعل هو اسرائيل تصفها بانها زياره هامه
وتاريخيه وتكشف بان وزير الخارجيه الي
كوهن سوف يدلي بتصريحات صحفيه بعد عودته
الى تل ابيب في حدود الساعه التاسعه
والنصف بتوقيت مكه المكرمه والاعلان
الصادر عن الخارجيه الاسرائيليه يتحدث عن
اهميه هذا المؤتمر الصحفي وعن انه غايه في
الاهميه وانه تاريخي اسرائيل تحقق انجازا
كبيرا دبلوماسيا في هذا السياق بحيث ان
لااءات الخرطوم الثلاث الشهيره لا للسلام
لا للمفاوضات لا للتطبيع مع اسرائيل تتحول
الان الى نعم واحده نعم للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل واسرائيل ترى في ذلك انجازا
دبلوماسيا كبيرا للغايه واختراقا لدوله
عربيه اخرى في سياق عمليات التطبيع
المتتاليه وايضا عمليا كسرا لما هو متعارف
عليه او كسرا لقرار الجامعه العربيه بان
التطبيع يجب ان النتيجه النهائيه للسلام
مع الفلسطينيين وليس العكس من يمين
نتنياهو يريد ان يثبت من خلال هذه الخطوه
الجديده انه بالامكان احداثه اختراق مع
دول عربيه واسلاميه وتحديدا دول في
افريقيا
وايضا في اسيا من اجل تطبيع هذه العلاقات
دون ان يحرز اي تقدم على المسار الفلسطيني
ودون ان يقدم اي تنازلات الفلسطينيين ودون
ان يعيد حتى لو شبر واحد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه للفلسطينيين هذا انجاز كبير
بالنسبه وهو واضح بان العلاقات العلاقات
التي كان يديرها بالاساس رئيس الموساد
وبعض الوزراء في الحكومات الاسرائيليه
السابقه يبدو انها اثمرت الان ويبدو ان
هذه الليله سوف يعلن وزير الخارجيه الي
كوهن ربما عن موعد
للتوقيع الرسمي على اتفاق التطبيق
العلاقات ما بين التل ابيب والخرطوم
لاسيما وان الاعلان المت بين الطرفين كان
في اكتوبر عام 2020 وبعد ذلك وقعت ايضا
الخرطوم على الجانب الاعلاني من اتفاق
ابراهام وبالتالي الان ربما سيكون التوقيع
على الاتفاق الثنائي في اطار هذه
الاتفاقيه التطبيعيه شكرا لك شكرا ايضا
لطائر المرضي